just on the case of this unnamed 19 year
old soldier who wanted to fight with the
Peshmerga and we understand this now
being sent back to his unit it's all
taking place within the space of about
five days he was on leave so can you
expect any punishment at all I think he
can because if he was ignored enough
what seems to be where he ended off we
would have been firstly in a prohibited
or restricted area which would itself be
a military offense
secondly if they went there as a
mercenary he would have fell foul of the
additional Geneva Convention principle
of 1977 that in itself is a civil
offence under the phone and listen and
act 18 17 but I won't don't think you'll
be will be looked at in that sort of
civil offense terms that hasn't been
that enacted since it first came in I
think he will be dealt with in as a
military offense not because he did
state law that he was going to be out of
a country for a year he was going to be
in visited territory so Vermaelen I
would think that he would be looked at
under a section 69 printed a conduct
regulation together and military
discipline or evacuate do you think it's
well advised to throw the book at him
legally in that way or would it be
better to that's go a bit more softly
well I think that the military
discipline system will look at this in a
fair proportion of effective and
transparent matter and it's for the
decision makers within that chain of
command to determine what these
sanctions healthy